all right i know we're all very it's
very oh it's four four days
before the election as stormy daniels
once said let's
let's just get this over with
right isn't that how you i tell you um
everything's going on at once the
election and it's [ __ ] halloween
tomorrow
and you know there's a full moon and we
got to set our clocks back
you can do that melania loves that by
the way she gets an ec
she gets an extra hour of pretending
she's asleep
but this election ah over you know this
over 80 million people have voted
already
wow and
and the supreme court says some even may
be counted so
that's no we never had anything
like this amount of early voting are you
kidding
it's good you know what they say the
early bird votes out the worm
uh and how about you know
how about a big thank you to the postal
workers of america i know they get a lot
of [ __ ]
they don't deserve it trump tried to
make it hard for them
trump has not been this scared of the
mail since the draft
[Laughter]
not that not that he's giving up by the
way there's a lot of voter intimidation
going on out there have you seen that on
the news a lot of trump
thugs harassing likely biden
voters you know they're poll watchers
they call themselves poll
you know what if he sees one of these
poll watchers point at your crotch and
go
you know what you can watch this poll
i got a poll you can watch
[Applause]
trump has been having is this a
coincidence he's been having three
rallies a day
and also covet 19 infection rates are
the highest ever
it's almost as if someone has been
traveling around the country super
spreading
it's like
trump's like if i'm going down i'm
taking everybody with me
but not here in california our rate uh
is low compared to the rest of the
country because he doesn't come here
because he doesn't come here
if we want covet here we'll get it the
old-fashioned way from justin turner
[Applause]
yeah there was also now we went all
through the white house
now pence there was a big outbreak in
mike pence's office five of his aides
were tested positive and his fly is on a
ventilator
i love this story phil collins latest
musician
a lot of them have tried to do that to
tell trump stop using my music
the rolling stones did this arrow smith
had to tell him neil young
elton john boy it is not easy being a
baby boomer trump fan your entire
playlist hates you
and of course uh we have a new supreme
court justice
amy coney barrett was sworn on monday
uh a new a supreme court judge and uh
this was eight days
before an election wow that's like
marrying a woman after her water breaks
really i mean she went to the court the
other day ruth bader ginsburg still had
stuff in the fridge
[Applause]
what what was so wrong about that one
we got to get the full crowd back
there's always going to be 20 with the
stick up their ass
no the writing is on the wall there with
the supreme court on roe versus wade
that getting overturned are you kidding
i was driving to work today i passed a
planned parenthood they had a sign out
front now providing anal bleaching
okay so this is it
oh you like anal i know bleaching's okay
but ruth bader
ginsburg's refrigerator was out of
bounds i will never understand audiences
okay uh so
this is it folks right are you ready did
you vote are you gonna vote
i mean this is this is the moment
i'm not gonna see you again until after
i'll see you on the other side
vote your conscience and by the way this
selection for this election
if you voted third party we're going to
give you a sticker that says i
[Applause]
farted
you